you were the one that broke the liver
King story yeah so did someone reach out
to you with the leaked blood work or
whatever the coach of liver King is a
friend of mine yeah so did the coach
feel like conflicted about it is that
why he oh yeah that's why he like
exposed him a lot of the inherent issue
with it was there was no disclosure in
any of the communications about hey I'm
gonna take the help you provide to then
Aid my fraudulent Mass scale yeah like
deception essentially so it was kind of
like I don't know kind of [ __ ] up to
put somebody in a position where you're
forcing them to like Aid in a bet your
yeah thing so does he actually follow
the [ __ ] that he says he does or is it
just like he's a complete fraud no he
follows it he subjects himself to like
intense hard work yeah and to get that
physique again it's not like you could
just take that stack and look anywhere
near him yeah like he very much
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] Derek I gotta return some
[ __ ] yeah